i'm talking about
a little bit about space lower bounds
for dynamic programming
and more particular on dynamic
programming on
3d compositions so this
um
one aim of this program is to have
matching upper and lower bounds
and yeah it's it's kind of
known that um dynamic programming can
very often be used to
speed up algorithms but it uses a lot of
space
and the question is whether it's really
necessary to use
so much space
under the assumption that you
really stick to dynamic programming so
you use dynamic programming
the standard algorithms use a lot of
space
is it really necessary to use this much
space
and yeah
so i'll concentrate here on dynamic
programming on 3d compositions
and there there are these tremendous
results about lower bounds and the time
complexity
so if we have a tree
decomposition as an input of size
n say and the width of the 3d
composition is k then
well we know for some time you can solve
these
if k is small you can solve
these problems in linear time and the
factor before the n
is 2 to the k for vertex cover and for
dominating set
and three coloring for example would be
three to the k
and it has been shown that um
under seth really you
cannot basically be better than that so
here we have
matching upper and lower bounds for the
time complexity
and if you look at the program
at the at the algorithms that achieve
the upper bound
then these are dynamic programming
algorithms
on the 3d composition
actually if you look at them closely
they really use
as much space as they use time here
oh that's a good question
this is a 3d composition of a graph
i didn't want to define this but now i
do it
so you have a graph and a tree
decomposition
is is a tree and the nodes in the tree
are usually called bags these are sets
of nodes from the graph
and this
they form a separator so if you
in the back you have these nodes then
these other parts from the tree so so
this node here will be separated from
i from c for example
and this is the most crucial
ingredient to get this dynamic
programming because
dynamic programming you will compute
some yeah
this is how dynamic before you compute
tables for
every
back here
and what the table contains this depends
on the problem
most the fastest algorithms on 3d
composition
they all work like that you know they
compute
tables and the dynamic program is
you compute the next table just by
looking at this table and this bag
and now you compute the table for this
bag just by looking at the old table and
the back and so on and here and here
here this
is a join node you look at these two
tables and you can compute a new table
and the space that you need is basically
the size of these tables
actually you don't have to store all
tables if you do it correctly you only
have to store three tables at the same
time
because you can always forget these
papers
after you you're here you don't need the
tables for this
most fastest algorithms
work like that and the space that you
need
for this computation that's basically
the size of these tables
and if i go back to these problems here
so the running time here is 2 to the k
times n the best algorithm
and the space that you need is actually
really 2 to the k
and here it's 3 to the k and here it's
also 3 to the k
and well can we do better
why we stick still stick to dynamic
programming
and i think
one problem when answering such
questions is
if i want to define something formal
about dynamic programming algorithms
i need a formal definition what a
dynamic programming algorithm is
i think it's impossible to give a formal
definition
dynamic programming this means you
compute something by computing
solutions for smaller sub problems and
combining them
how can you make a formal definition out
of this
i think this is not possible if you
stick to
this special kind of dynamic programming
on a 3d composition i think you
you can make a formal definition
in this talk i'll go a different way
i use a more general model
which which can be defined very easily
but
it every dynamic programming
algorithm works on on this model
that's easy to see i think and the model
is uh basically a turing machine
as you use it if you are interested in
space complexity
which means the input is is on a
separate tape
which is read only and you have a
working tape where you this is a read
write tape
and if you count the space complexity
you're just counting this working tape
and you disregard the input
tape so that's how you
do space complexity and if you want to
go to dynamic programming the only
change i do to this model
is i'm just saying well the input tape
is
one way so you can just read it from
left to right and you cannot go back
so you can ask well why would somebody
be so stupid
to not be able to
peak in advance or go back when
i don't know but dynamic programming 3d
compositions all algorithms
don't do that you don't look
at the end what happens you don't even
know
how long the input will be you just read
your
bags one after the other computer tables
all algorithms work like that
so
i assume that you get the 3d composition
here is the input not the graph
but already the tweeting in the right
order of course otherwise
this would be cruel i guess yeah
it sounds like the whole question could
be the order on the tape because if the
order is such that
the solution let's say in some cases and
if you're looking for just the first
the beginning of the tape then maybe
it's easy to do it
you get this in in a topological order
of course
so so that you can compute this here
this if you get it in the wrong order
then
this would really be not nice yeah so
i assume you get the 3d composition here
in the correct order
and
you only need to store three tables okay
why do i need only to store three tables
well
if it's a join node i have to look at
these two tables while i compute the
third one but
you can also always assume if it's that
it's a binary tree and if not
if it's not a binary tree you can always
uh
combine these two and then
in order to get to the root you need to
store i mean
how do you maintain the part of the tree
that you're
well you can also use more i i don't
care
but
you might be right actually i
i don't want to think about this at the
moment
i can discuss it later
okay so that's my model
and well
to compute now to to prove space lower
bounds it's a
basically a mild narrowed argument
so what i want to do is i will construct
lots of graphs that trick the machine
into giving
the wrong answer if the space is too
small
so many many graphs and if there are
many many many graphs this means that
if the working tape is too small
that after reading two of these graphs
the machine will be in the same
configuration
so i want to for three coloring i want
to prove a lower
bound of roughly 3 to the k so that
means if the
i mean that means i need roughly 2 to
the 3 to decay different graphs that are
all different
then i have i can
i cannot distinguish them with log of
this number many bits
which would be 3 to the k but
it's not completely trivial to do that
because you need
you have all all kind of sign conditions
to do that
so first of all so so more
precisely this family of graphs it
should not be too big but it's here size
is roughly three to the k
and the three width or path widths which
is even better
it should be small and here it's roughly
k
and technically i construct it by using
these are all bordered graphs and let's
say x is the border so so the x
k distinguished vertices
and they will be
actually they will be in every bag of
the 3d composition
but at the end the last bag will contain
just this
this set x and all these graphs will be
three colorable
but in different ways so
for every way the x
the whole graph can be colored in such a
way that x has
it has a given coloring i will
okay 3 to the k different ways
i can color the x right because the size
is k so
three to the k different ways in
principle to color x
and now you can choose which which ways
to color x
can really happen and which not so then
that
this is there are two to the three to
the k possibilities to do that
and for every of these possibilities i
want to build a graph
where exactly these colorings are
possible and
the other colorings that you didn't
choose are not possible
right and actually the minus one is
because
uh one is missing because actually
it should be minus six i see that now
because all of them have to be colorable
so there's of course one possibility
where it's not colorable
and i divide you by six because actually
um yeah i forbid colorings but
it doesn't matter where which color is
rare so i can
still have these six permutations of the
colors
so this construction is surprisingly
simple here
because what i do is i just
use this gadget to forbid all colors
all colorings that should be forbidden
so here is this
set x and let's say i want to forbid
this special coloring that these are all
red
these are all blue and these are all
green or
or the other way around this green and
this blue but but
this partition right here one color here
one color here one color here
so i want to forbid this and this gadget
does the job
um yeah let's assume these all are all
red
yeah okay then these two cannot be read
and this has to be again red
and if these two are then this has to be
red if these
two are red then this has to be red and
so on same happens here
so we will have a red here a blue here a
green here and then this
vertex a there's no color left so you
you cannot color it like this but if you
look at it closely if there's any other
partition here
it's always possible to color so with
this gadget i can just forbid
one special way to color x and now what
i do
is i just attach all these
up to three to the k gadgets to the set
x
for every way to color it that i want to
forbid i attach such a gadget
so i have a graph size is roughly k
times 3 to the k
and
if i look at two of these graphs there's
always one
coloring where one graph can be colored
like that
and the other one cannot
and that's what i feed to the turing
machine these graphs
and after the turing machine reads the
graph
it's in some configurations
i haven't talked about this here
why is the artwork small
because you can put all these in in one
bag
and then you're just left with a tree of
height lock k
which has path with
okay and they are all separated by this
so
it has low pathways which is of course
important
so i feed to the turing machine all
these graphs
and because the space
so if the space is only three minus
epsilon to the k
but there are three to the k graphs
they're two to the three to the k graphs
right
for two of them the turing machine will
be in the same configuration and now
i can just add another
it to the graph where which tests
were like some coloring which forces
some coloring
just taking a triangle and putting it in
and connecting the three vertices to to
to the partition that i want to force
so i force a coloring and this means
i will get a yes instance for g sub 1
plus
h and then i will get a no instance for
the other one
but because when they start to read
the last part of of the input their
turing machines are in the same
configuration one of them will give the
wrong answer
so it's not possible to do that
so just vertex cover
it's also very simple to do that
dominating set
surprisingly works too but it's just
very complicated the gadget so it's
in my opinion it's it's not it's not
clear that you can do this with all
problems
because uh for for the coloring this was
the forbidding colors was not
influencing
each other for dominating set this is
not at all clear that
this is possible because for dominating
set i i also
need the 2 to the 3 to the k different
states
and for dominating set well if you
want to
boundary graph and now
we want to just have information on this
border here and and don't look at the
rest of the graph
for dominating set you would say yeah i
need obviously three states
whether it's in the dominating set or
it's not in the dominating set but
already dominated or on the third state
it is not in the dominating world but
not dominated
then you can pull off this timing
programming
and yeah i have a question about the
theorem so like this one are you saying
that
there is a path decomposition and a way
to order it
so that small space is not enough or are
you saying no matter how you
order it and no matter what part the
composition you have
yeah it doesn't matter how you order it
so for all orderings this one
like these are really different graphs
each one of them
so each one of them you can order
differently or
yeah i don't care this
even then you have even more
possibilities right so all i need is
that i have
three a two to the three to the k graphs
which are mutually distinguishable by
attaching
something at the end
when you say at the end doesn't this
presume in water
yeah the h so the h comes at the end
so if the h comes at the beginning then
it's very easy to solve
okay so there exists an ordering so that
you can't do it
okay yes
you instead of attaching the edge you
could do something different by just
forbidding everything else that you
don't want to allow right and enforce
the coloring like that
and if you do it like this then i think
the ordering should not be important at
all
but is it possible to have a graph
of course if you if you think of such a
state you can construct a graph that has
exactly the state right
but now you you have three to the k
different states and you want to
construct the graph that has
the first state but not the second one
and not the third one but this
force it has and so on and all possible
combinations it's not clear that this is
so now what we have is
really
kind of we have a lower bound on this
base which matches the upper bound and
simultaneously the same for the time
this is not so bad but of course it
assumes that it's dynamic programming
so it's very specialized and it would be
much nicer to have something without
this
assumption but on the other hand
we do this dynamic programming all the
time and
and now i would say like to say a few
words
so so what does it mean um this law
about on the space does it mean
we really use a lot of space and
i'm not completely sure what it means
you can have a pessimistic or an
optimistic
approach how to interpret this
so
let's see the lower bound here
requires us to have a really big input
otherwise it doesn't work
but if the input is is also 3 to the kb
then 3 to the k is relatively small so
the space
consumption is not so big you could say
that right
and if the input is is much smaller
then even smaller than 3 to the k
then this is kind of strange because
then the tables are very big
but they were constructed from a very
short input which means the kolmogorov
complexity has to be much smaller than
for example 3 to the k so in principle
it should be possible
to compress them which is not true
if the input becomes really very long
three to the k
log then it's not possible to compress
them anymore
as this theorem states
can we compress the tables well it's
not clear because just having a small
kolmogorov complexity doesn't mean
you can compress it in practice because
you need time
resource for that and you this might not
work
i can tell you that this is kind of
long ago we did some experiments
because we were annoyed how much space
this all this dynamic programming takes
and if you look at at the table for
vertex cover for example so you have
some
entry like this and it says
like 217 for example which means if this
node is in the vertex cover this is not
this is in the vertices and this is the
border here
and the table says well the best vertex
cover that you can get
if this is in these three are in and
these are out
is 217. so the table is much bigger and
let's say there's another entry
which looks like this and it happens to
be 218 here
so it's almost the same right but here's
a one more
so this is in the vertex cover here it's
not in the vertex cover
so under this condition the best vertex
cover is 217 big
under these conditions it's 218. so what
you can do is you
just don't store this just don't store
it
because you already know that you can
get 217
with this and you just put this in this
cannot destroy a vertex cover because of
monotonicity
and you get 218 so so you don't have to
store this
this is a very simple rule but there are
some other rules like this
and what we and surprisingly if you if
you really don't store this
you can still do the dynamic programming
very efficiently
so we tried this and it was very
frustrating because this
was just working and it didn't use much
space
and we were trying to to get some graphs
where this does not work right where the
space
goes up it was impossible so we could
solve
for example a three bits of 40
and we couldn't find an example where
this would
use too much memory
went up to 60 and this was still
sometimes working
so compression seems to work if the
input is small
but this is a very specialized
compression but maybe
maybe it works in a more general setting
so i was thinking about like
what if we store the table not as a
table
but as an obdd or something
so in practice this very often reduces
the complexity
a lot so we didn't try that but that
might just work
um on the other hand
if you look at this pessimistically you
would say in the fpt framework we always
we say fpt algorithms make sense if the
parameter is small
and that means n should be big if you
use
algorithms like that otherwise you might
be better off using something else
but if the big and is really big then
this lower bound just
kicks in and then it means you really
need a
exponential space in k
yeah i think the big question is
all these algorithms use dynamic
programming
can you do something else and
well so far nobody has found something
so you can also use branching on 3d
compositions but then the spice
the time complexity just explodes and it
goes from fbt to
xp
okay maybe
it would be very nice to to to tackle
this problem really
with out forcing dynamic programming
so we should think of what if we have an
algorithm with optimal running time
can you under some assumption some
complexity theoretic assumption this
proof
that you can solve these problems in
poly
k time space so
just polynomial space in k but
let's say for three coloring you you
really run in 3 to the k
times n and you use poly k space
can you disprove this under some
i think and nobody can do that at the
moment but on the other hand
the lower bounds here they are so great
and i i think
10 years ago nobody would have dreamed
that this might be possible
and now we just have it so
so i i think the question makes also
sense for space
so okay that's the question on this
question
and so wouldn't this like in full
generality of this question like
just a new lower bounds on like your
general killing machine computation that
you're gonna
like separating from your space or
things like that yeah
but it it's always relative to
hypothesis otherwise there's no hope i
guess
but with with seth we have
come such a long way
without these results without the time
law
matching bounds for for the time
complexity i would be very pessimistic
i think now that this exists i'm not so
pessimistic
might be something for for space too
i have to say from from own experiments
space
is still expensive today
so it just takes a couple of seconds to
to fill up the space
like 20 seconds or something but i have
more than 20 seconds
but the space is is gone so
maybe in the near future we will have so
much space that we cannot feel it in our
lifetime but
at the moment we are not there
okay but so this concludes my talk
other problems that do not involve
treating comprehension like
the importance i know
i'm not aware of these things but
in the past that for example the
hamiltonian path problem
this was you can solve it in n factorial
time easily with
polynomial space and then there's the
dynamic programming algorithm which
speeds up it to two to the n but uses a
lot of space
i think i'm not i'm not sure but i think
there was
some discussion whether this is really
necessary i'm not sure and people might
have said
i'm not sure that yeah this might be
unavoidable but but we have seen that
it's not true
and many times dynamic programming
was helping to speed up problems but
later even better algorithms came
along and and they didn't use so much
space and were even faster so for
example with the color coding
color coding was also fast but
but memory intensive but now we have
even faster algorithms
so i'm i'm not so sure whether this is
really necessary
so and this makes it even more important
to answer i think so unsecure
at the moment whether the space is
necessary and
if you know that it's necessary then
it's good but
maybe not so so very often i think it
has been shown that
with a clever new technique you can get
rid of this exponential space
a little bit on the discussion that was
going on previously
i my impression or my thinking is that
um if you think about all this in terms
of pre-automata
and then um i mean it is clear that you
are talking about sort of any um
ordering as an impossible input that is
a topological ordering of
your previously directed tree because
then
all you are saying is basically my only
wrote arguments for trees
first of all and secondly in the same
spirit
i'm not surprised that in practice you
get these kind of compressions
because what are you doing you are
basically picking an
arbitrary transition function of of a
tree argument
and of course you can minimize it a
little bit if it's just arbitrary
um it's very hard to pick a minimize
i have a different opinion on that
i think my opinion when you take a
textbook
dynamic programming algorithm and
especially so if you do it
for for 3d composition and you take it
from the textbook
and don't modify it it uses
this table size from the beginning so it
uses a lot of memory even if the input
is is
very small so so so this is not
automatically
compressing or something there is
nothing else then
trying to apply one same relationship
of any of your favorite state
minimization algorithms
okay in this sense it is clear that you
can do it
and last i think you mentioned
convergent complexity i mean you know
that there's an alternative way
to incorporate miami road in terms of
commercial complexity
and also then i mean i don't think
that you can really compress it uh like
like public
uh
i think at the moment nobody has an idea
how such an algorithm would work like
but it's clear that it cannot be dynamic
programming right yes cannot use that
has to be something
different from dynamic programming
we automatically dynamic programming
yeah that can't work
regarding your last question uh i
believe that there is a recent work of
allender at all from last year i think
or two years ago
that basically excludes the existence of
such algorithm poly kai times poly
log l under the assumption of an
l naught contained in sc which is
equivalent to saying that
nl is not contained in problems that can
be solved in polynomial polynomial time
and
mixed by simultaneously which is sort of
a
standard assumption in in in
yeah okay then basically
this here but not not very convincingly
we're working on on some kind of this
stuff but for
for polynomial space poly poly and space
and we had some some partial results
there so
but i i i wasn't aware of this but this
is exactly
what what i was hoping something like
that right so
follow the results of allah and we even
phrase it in our paper explicitly
that this question isn't possible to get
it
it's equivalent to analysis contained in
usd
yeah this is uh this is exactly
what i was hoping in the future but
okay it already exists i'm happy to hear
that
yeah this is one question list and so so
it basically means we have to live with
this exponent
maybe not exponential but but
non-polynomial space right
yeah this is basically the conclusion
there's a
the question basically that is not
really
investigated well meaning we don't know
the real answer
is what what happens when you allow
polyand space
so poly polly k times polylock and
it's basically we understand what's
happening there when you allow
this is sort of a different question yes
because suddenly when your decomposition
is large you still have a lot of space
yes and this question is if we don't
know we don't see any very convincing
answers there but there are some results
that give us
some some partial uh for partial
intuition what is the answer
yeah i'm already very happy about about
this one
it's it's what i would expect everybody
expects is i guess so
but as i said it's it's it's better to
know right so
otherwise you you don't
then you have some conclusion
are suggesting some form of trade-off
there are lots of trade-offs if you if
you allow more
time here you can have less for example
if you allow
n to the o of k time you can do it in
polynomial space
and you can mix it a bit
so you can mix branch divide and conquer
basically and dynamic programming and
you can find some sweet spot
until your memory is full then you start
branching right
so this is possible but it's kind of
ugly i think
another question let's thank peter again